دبلوماسيه بين البلديه
ان نفصلها الى جزئين الجزء الاول بمشاركه
الزملاء من مختلف الوزارات والهيئات
وبعد ذلك الجزء الثاني المتماثله في مادبه
الغداء ونحن نتبادل لاراء وجها
فرصه للمناقشه المفصله لكافه المواضيع
التي تهم الطرفين
فخامه رئيس اهلا وسهلا
موسكو ونلتقي لكي نناقش الكثير من الملفات
الهامه المطروحه امام دولتين
قد تطلب منا ان نلتقي ونضع تصورات مشتركه
للمرحله القادمه
للحكومه الروسيه ممثله الطوارئ على
المساعدات الكبيره التي قدمت خلال زلزال
الذي اصاب سوريا الشهر الماضي
مساهمه مباشره في انقاذ المصابين في هذا
الزلزال
والذي كان له تاثير كبير في التخفيف عن
المصابين وفي التخفيف من اثار الزلزال على
المواطنين سوريا
[موسيقى]
للمواقف الثابته تجاه الحرب في سوريا
موقف المنطلقه من وحده اراضي الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه وسياده دولتها
[موسيقى]
في حاله حرب
ولكن
[موسيقى]
اريد ان
استغل هذه الزياره الاولى لي بعد بدء
الحرب في اوكرانيا
في دعم الموقف السوري من هذه
الحرب ضد النازيه القديمه الجديده
لان هذه النازيه دعمتها دعمها الغرب قبل
الحرب العالميه الثانيه واحتضن قادتها بعد
الحرب والان هو يستمر في دعمه كما كان
سابقا اياك
موقفنا لا ينطلق اليوم من الصداقه القويه
بيننا
ولا من الوفاء لمواقف سوريا
[موسيقى]
بين المسؤولين السوريين والروس في اللجنه
المشتركه التي حصل خلال ايام الماضيه
والذي كان من افضل الاجتماعات التي تمت
خمار خلال السنوات الماضيه
التي توصل اليها هذه المره ست
ستمهد لمرحله جديده من التعاون الاقتصادي
فيها افكار وليس مجرد بيانات
لنهايه
الرئيس على استقبالكم واكد ان هذه زياره
ستمهد لمرحله جديده في العلاقات السوريه
الروسيه في على كل المستويات
نتائج حقيقيه يمكننا نبني عليها للمرحله
القادمه في العلاقات بين بلدينا والشعبين